why am I here yes because it's my  military duty only 0.5% of the  population survived for every one  survivor there are a thousand dead for  centuries you believed in someone you've  never seen millions just like me will be  here soon they will all want the same  thing  you'll do what you were created for  [Music]  as we all know if something happened 24  days ago and all contact was lost that  most of the world everything outside of  this circle is in complete darkness as  of now we'll make anyone still alive in  the quarantine zone attack us  they're 160 million of them people  not really  contact with command is lost and where  everybody's last home  do you think they're going to take  Moscow the war has begun  [Music]  you